last august biden earned the contempt
and disgust of the whole world as we saw
those heart-wrenching images coming out
of afghanistan following his
catastrophic surrender to the taliban
and botched withdrawal
desperate afghans clinging on to
aircraft
falling to their deaths
innocent families
standing
waist deep in bloody sewer water
passports and visa applications in hand
pleading to be rescued
and who could forget the scene at dover
air force base as flag draped coffins
carrying the bodies of 13 american
service members was solemnly transferred
to their final resting places as biden
impatiently checked his watch every few
minutes
but soon the establishment media was
eager to move on just like their bosses
and the biden regime wanted them to to
help biden save face and try to rescue
his floundering domestic agenda by
october you could barely find a mention
of afghanistan the thousands of
americans and our allies trapped behind
enemy lines the barbarity of the newly
installed taliban regime the continuing
horror as the consequences of biden's
disastrous withdrawal play out so the
news
turned to domestic concerns biden's
domestic disasters the inflation crisis
he created the supply chain crisis he
created of course the border crisis he
created but that doesn't mean the
afghanistan crisis just went away in
fact in many ways the real repercussions
of the biden regimes cruelty and
incompetence were just beginning and if
there's one story
that captures that better than any other
it's this
utterly horrifying report to their
credit produced by cnn
here are the shocking details
the situation inside afghanistan has now
gotten so dire
some families have been forced to sell
their own children
just to buy food
since the taliban takeover two and a
half months ago any money or assistance
has dried up
and with eight mouths to feed parwana's
father is now doing the unthinkable
my father has sold me because we don't
have bread rice and flour he has sold me
to an old man
as he carries her only bag of belongings
she again resists
digging her heels into the dirt
but it's futile
it was really hard to watch just
unbelievable parents selling their
daughters
there were multiple examples all with
direct first-hand testimony in that
report it's happening all over the
country here's another example a
sold
for 550
this is what biden has done this is what
he's done this appalling man
masquerading as a president this vain
bumbling old fool who overruled everyone
on the ground just because he wanted to
make some sick speech on the anniversary
of 9 11 about ending the war well he
didn't end the war he restarted it as
the very people who attacked us on 9 11
literally take over the afghan interior
ministry and the country once again
becomes a safe haven for terrorists and
in the process of pushing through his
calamitous scheme the most humiliating
foreign policy fiasco in american
history
biden has created in afghanistan a
humanitarian crisis of vast proportions
a new report projects
that over the course of the next year
virtually the entire country will be
engulfed in universal abject poverty
meanwhile there are still u.s citizens
trapped in afghanistan green card
holders their families
who the state department shamefully
still refuses to rescue
and the taliban they horse around on
carnival rides and parade the billions
of dollars worth of military equipment
biden left behind while their fellow
countrymen suffer and starve yes while
parents are forced to sell their
children for food
parents selling their children
that's what biden has done the most
unimaginable cruelty and suffering
caused by biden
was that what he meant by restoring the
soul of the nation american policy
causing child slavery
it is truly despicable he biden is truly
despicable he will never ever live this
down
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now